[Music]
the things I envy the most is I is when
someone can write music and you you
write great songs and I was just curious
what's your process I don't need because
I don't I don't know how to write music
I like to play music but I don't know
how to write it
what's your process when you're writing
a song it's always different sometimes
things come to me in dreams and
sometimes I'll like write things on my
hand and write it down in my phone it's
always different but one of the more
recent things about how I've been
writing music recently is um do you
write on like a guitar do you write it I
read a guitar but I also write on piano
and it started as like a joke but then
it seriously has produced some of my
favorite songs on my new record and what
I do is I turn off all the lights and I
walk over to the piano and I gently
lower myself my boobs
your breasts yeah my boobs is fine boobs
I shoulda stopped it feel you won't you
put you lower them and they and they
they go on to the music keys and I just
let them
tickle the ivories wait a minute
you lure them they think this is how
Gershwin did it you lower them
let's and then you wiggle you like some
vibrato and then you like and then you
can I go I can move around they come on
they're moving around
[Laughter]
wow that's incredible yeah they really
just go crazy and then all of a sudden I
have these great they have a mind of
their own they do never like
quiet you two although you're laughing
at very no I didn't need to make light
of this process but good god no
multifunctional really yeah has anyone
ever walked in on you when you were
banging away yeah that can get weird
your songs you have a lot of a lot of
the lyrics and your songs are metaphors
for other things yeah yeah which is
quite you got one okay for one one of my
songs is dinosaur and that's about we're
that's about old guys old guys are
dinosaurs well then when you hit on me
when you're like a billion and you're
like hey and then it's kind of like it's
kind of like a male cougar right so so
uh so so yeah but see like I told you
before the whole like dinosaur thing
that I love like I just love dinosaurs
like actual dinosaurs like ah that was a
parrot
okay so that's dinosaurs right so you
but so people need to know the code
right I guess yeah and then there's also
a song called grow a pair it's not
actually about the fruit that I'd
figured out then there's another one
called gold Trans Am and it is like
about my car's supercool right but it's
also about like my I don't know washing
machine just point to the Conan yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]